[Music]
get out get out get out is the
directorial debut of Jordan Peele you
may know from Key & Peele a very very
hilarious sketch comedy show that I've
been a big fan of I like the movie Keanu
I didn't love it but I really think this
guy's talented as well as Keegan they're
both hilarious so I was very curious to
see where Jordan Peele could bring to a
horror film and this is definitely told
from a very unique perspective we don't
commonly see in genre filmmaking at the
center of the film is a Mantid in the
middle of an interracial relationship
and he's told by a girlfriend he's about
to meet her family for the first time
although they are unaware of the fact
that he's black and so that really makes
him feel awkward when he gets there
though all seems okay for a while until
he begins to realize there's some
sinister stuff going on behind the
scenes I'm a big fan of horror you guys
know that I've loved these movies in my
entire life and when a good one comes
along it gives me the chills it gives me
the tingles it gives me something to
think about and talk about and it
inspires me that's why when I saw the
trailer for this movie I was
particularly enticed because it's
definitely a courageous viewpoint you
don't commonly see films like this told
from this perspective and I got to say
walking out of it I'm really impressed
with Jordan Peele and I cannot wait to
see what else he does this is a very
special debut because not only does he
show that he understands how to direct
genre films how to make a horror scene
interesting or fun particularly the
fantastic opening scene that to my
knowledge was one take which I really
liked but also that his singular voice
can be maintained and come through your
stereotypical genre filmmaking because
yes this film has a lot of horror tropes
jump-scares things popping out of you
people walking past the hallway corridor
accompanied by a loud jolt of music but
all through that it maintains its
originality because of its central story
and that unique perspective is told
through quite a bit of racial commentary
and satire because this film definitely
has a satirical edge to it and there are
a lot of moments throughout the movie
they cause some serious laughter to come
from the entire audience because it
understands that although this is a over
the top for a movie with some very
sinister elements behind the scenes
there's definitely something to be said
about the awkwardness that one feels
when he's in the middle of something
that he's not entirely used to and in
this case Jordan Peele had said that he
does sometimes feel very awkward when
he's the only black person around and so
we wanted to tell a story from the
perspective of somebody dealing with
that see I grew up in a very mixed race
environment I had tons of friends of
color so I never really saw this myself
personally I grew up in a very
all-inclusive family that believed that
everyone is people we're all human and
like it doesn't matter and I still feel
that way and I'm really really grateful
for that upbringing because I've since
learned as an adult that that's rare
so seeing a film like this can sometimes
get under my skin because I genuinely
don't understand racism and that's
because I never was really exposed to it
on a full scale so when I see it in
movies like this I have a hard time
connecting with it and that's why I am
so glad that Jordan Peele wrote and
directed this movie because he has taken
this aspect of the story that could get
under a lot of people's skin
and made it so refreshing from his
viewpoint because he has some amazing
comic relief from lil rel Howery who
stole every scene he was in this guy--
look for him man he is going to be in so
much now he was so fricking hilarious in
this movie he had cane stitches in
virtually every single sequence so
Jordan Peele understands the seriousness
of this subject matter but also he is
able to find considerable humor in it
and that was so refreshing daniel Kaluga
plays the lead character and i apologize
sir if I said your name incorrectly I
thought he was brilliant in the film I
didn't realize until after I saw it that
he's actually from London his accent is
perfect I didn't even know for a second
he was from the UK fantastic performance
Bradley Whitford is also really funny
and good in this film really all around
the performances are very strong there's
a good sense to the horror as well
towards the third act that builds to
some really satisfying moments that had
a lot of people in my audience cheering
as for issues with this movie there was
a shot in the trailer of a roaring deer
skeletal monster and I was really
enticed by that and I was excited to see
where that would play into this film
it's not in the movie though I hate when
trailers do that when I insert things in
their trailer
that end up just being on the cutting
room floor road one excuse me that was a
still getting over that cold sorry also
sometimes the pacing does suffer there
are a lot of sequences that are just
very weird that are meant to make you
feel like you're watching a very awkward
episode of The Twilight Zone and
sometimes it works but there are other
times where you jump between tones a
little too quickly also there's some
scares in the movie that in retrospect
don't really make sense there's one
sequence where this guy is just running
at full speed towards our main character
and then he just kind of darts to the
right instantly in retrospect once I
know what's going on under the surface
of this movie I don't really get what's
happening there it seemed like it was
just a scare meant for the audience and
it doesn't really do much for the story
I think you'll enjoy yourself I'm
impressed with the way Jordan Peele
handled this directorial debut his voice
is still heard while also being a very
entertaining genre film for horror fans
the pacing does suffer sometimes it's
not a perfect tone and sometimes the
humor does feel a little tacked on and
I'm looking forward to seeing it again
I'm going to give get out a B+ guys
thank you so much as always for watching
I do hope you checked out my review of
angel's egg I did a very in-depth
analysis of a 1985 anime film directed
by Mamoru Oshii that I think is very
special I thank you also for all the
people who have reached out to criterion
hopefully we'll get a release one day if
they can notice us little people here
you know scrambling for our anime or
whatever but guys thank you so much as
always for watching I do hope you check
out that angels egg video I'm gonna have
a link to that in a second you guys are
the best thank you very much and if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
you
[Applause]
[Music]